and this is why a lot of times we really
see conservatives default to
egalitarianism like we are equal we are
the same that's why when we hear
cheating right what is the default from
conservatives if I say you know we
should work through cheating for the men
they'll say well what about when a woman
cheats should the man stay again that's
the default to egalitarianism when we
covered Twitter erupting because Rachel
said her husband doesn't do chores they
default to egalitarianism and say well
if he loved her he would help well why
can't he help with the chores and again
relationships just work better when
people play their role when women don't
expect men to help out with the domestic
work